so timothy gardner you've recently
compared brexit to a soap opera but is
it really a soap opera or is it a
serious threat to the continent of
europe well
a british tragedy is also a farce right
and it it's both those things at the
same time
in my view the negative consequences
for europe could be even more serious
than those for britain
in what way because we already
see a lot of forces of populism
nationalism and disintegration
in different ways in the european union
and brexit could give a big big push to
those forces
and is there anything that the european
union can do to counter that
i hope that they will be doing it this
wednesday
evening when they give a long flexible
extension for brexit because that gives
a chance for a democratic process
which will end up either with a second
referendum and britain may be staying in
the eu which would be a fantastic chance
for europe or with the softer brexit
and both those outcomes are less bad for
europe and you think that there is um
also in europe a perception that britain
needs to go through this
it sort of needs to get it out of its
system this brexit and needs it for
for its national soul so i hear more and
more the argument
in continental europe that
britain is going to be such a
problematic member of the eu
the metaphor of cancer or poison is used
but if we're thinking about long term
for decades the prospects for the
european union long term
in relation to china to trump's america
to climate change
then it's clearly better to have britain
inside
so it wouldn't be easy initially but
we'd get through it and we'd be a better
place at the end what do you think if
there was no deal what would be the
actual outcome what would it mean for
for the relations with the eu i think it
would be poisoned for
a generation i think that'd be a
huge blame game um
and we would blame it on continental
europe the brits would blame it on
continental europe not me but the brits
and the continental europe would blame
it on the brits
and then the economic fallout would be
really dark
very very serious indeed some brexiteers
are arguing actually it would be better
for
europe better for the eu to not have
britain because then
europe could move on and could be more
integrationist
this this may be a surprising thought
for many of your viewers
in the end i think britain or maybe just
england will be okay
we'll sort of muddle through somehow
we'll be poorer weaker less influential
but we'll be okay
but i'm not so sure the european union
longer term
will be okay tomorrow thank you very
much
my pleasure
so budget so timothy had a timothy
gartner casting doubt on whether the eu
is going to survive
can people like him offer a solution for
the current political deadlock the uk is
in
he doesn't pretend that he has a magic
wand but he hopes
for the democratic process to to take
over he
puts his hope in parliament he says
democracy is messy and sometimes it
takes time
but we need to go through this we need
to go through this process
and it might take some weeks it might
take months but he's hoping that
parliament
in the end will find a solution and he
said he's actually very proud of
parliament at the moment he's proud of
the uh
the stance that many mps have been
taking and the passionate speeches
they've been giving
and he wants to to see this uh
transformed into action he also says
well
if they haven't got that by the end of
the year though even he is giving up
oh goodness all right berget mass
reporting for us from london thanks so
much